IF YOU GET RID OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, YOU'LL BE STRANDING
MILLIONS OF WOMEN WITHOUT
HEALTHCARE.
SO WHERE WILL THESE MILLIONS OF
WOMEN GO.
>> WE WILL BE FINE, LARRY.
>> Larry: OH, IT'S HOLLY. HOLLY
WALKER, EVERYONE.
ARE YOU IN A STARBUCKS BATHROOM?
>> YEP.
>> Larry: THIS IS WHERE I AM
GETTING MY PAP NOW.
A NICE HOMELESS MAN SAID HE
WOULD DO IT FOR A HANDY AND A
A HALF A BANANA.
WHAT A SCORE!
>> Larry: WHOA, WHOA, HOLLY,
NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT SAFE!.
YOU NEED TO SEE A REAL DOCTOR.
WELL, TOO LATE, CAPTAIN AFTER
THE PROCEDURE.
>> Larry: SORRY.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> LARRY IS RIGHT, HOLLY.
YOU SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN YOURS
DONE HERE.
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD, IT'S ROBIN
THEDE, EVERYONE.
ARE YOU IN THE SUBWAY?
>> YEP. THE 4 TRAIN, LARRY.
OR THE CLEAN GREEN, I LIKE TO
CALL IT.
>> Larry: THERE IS NOTHING
CLEAN ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T THINK YOU THOUGHT THIS
THROUGH.
>> THINKING HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS, LARRY.
ONCE YOU DEFUND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, YOU TAKE WHAT YOU
CAN GET.
PLUS  I AM GETTING A PAP SMEAR
PRACTICALLY EVERY TIME I TAKE
THE RUSH HOUR TRAIN.
>> Larry: AND, ROBIN, WHO
WOULD EVEN PERSONAL THIS ON THE
SUBWAY.
>> THOSE GUYS WHO DANCE ON THE
IT IS SHOW TIME!
>> Larry: ROBIN.
THOSE GUYS ARE TALENTED, BUT I
DON'T THINK THEY ARE THAT
TALENTED.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> HOLLY, ROBIN YOU HAVE IT ALL
WRONG.
>> Larry: MIKE, WAIT, IS THAT
MIKE?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING, MIKE?
>> I'M SMEARING WITH
SOLIDARITY.
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD.
I'M SORRY, MIKE BUT THAT IS
NOT RIGHT AT ALL.
>> DEFUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD
IS NOT RIGHT.
>> Larry: THAT'S TRUE.
WHY ARE YOU AT RAND PAUL
HEADQUARTERS?
IS HE GIVING OUT PAP SMEARS?
>> IF HE'S TAKING AWAY WOMEN'S
HEALTH SERVICES, HE BETTER BE.
>> TELL HIM, MIKE! THAT'S RIGHT!